Years after Disney's acquisition of Lucasfilm, the
release of new "Star Wars" movies and TV series
has become something of a regular occurrence. In
the early days of Disney "Star Wars," however,
the franchise's new owners handled the
property at a comparatively slower pace,
using their knowledge of the Force to build
huge levels of anticipation before each release.
"That's not how the Force works."
The first two entries in Disney's
"Star Wars" trilogy, then,
were all the more important
at the time of their release,
given that they provided fans with some of their
first insights into the franchise's current
era. Among the key contributions of those
early films was the introduction of Rey,
portrayed by newcomer Daisy Ridley as Rey.
Adam Driver also stars opposite Ridley as
the villainous Kylo Ren, a dark side Jedi as
well as the son of Han Solo and Princess Leia.
In an interview with Oh My Disney, Driver
discussed what it was like working with
Ridley on Disney's first two Skywalker
saga films, sharing some rare insight
into the real-life human being behind one
of the early pillars of modern "Star Wars."
Amidst a larger behind-the-scenes discussion
about their time spent making "Star Wars:
The Force Awakens" and "The Last Jedi," Oh My
Disney asked Daisy Ridley and Adam Driver each
what their experience was like working with the
other performer. According to Driver, Ridley was
a wholly positive presence on set, both in their
personal interactions and in her acting work.
"It's easy to be in scenes with
her because I could listen to her
all day. She has just great instincts."
For what it's worth, Ridley spoke of acting
opposite Driver in similarly glowing terms.
"He is so amazing in this film. Seriously.
I can't speak highly enough about him. In
the very basic sense of it all, he
is the most amazing scene partner."
By all indications, Ridley appears to be someone
alongside whom Driver had a
great time working on-set.
As it turns out, Adam Driver's time spent
working with Daisy Ridley ended up blossoming
into a full-fledged friendship. Among a number of
other topics — some related to "Star Wars," some
not — the two further discussed their relationship
with one another in an interview published by V
Magazine. In fact, it wasn't so much an interview
as a remote conversation between the two.
"I'd rather not do this now. Yeah,
me too. Why did you hate your fath.."
At one point in their conversation, in
response to a question about whether or
not she prefers meeting her co-stars prior to
filming, Ridley mentioned that she and Driver
eventually became great friends. The reason
it took so long? Well, it wasn't because
they didn't enjoy being with each other
on set. As Ridley said in the interview:
"Adam, we became besties last year, but we had
met some years before. It really takes me a while
to relax with people. I don’t think I’m very good
at meeting people: I feel awfully uncomfortable."
Considering the interview's 2017 publication
date, this means that they most likely became
official besties at some point during their time
spent on the set of "The Last Jedi" together.
In response, Driver told her, quote, "you always
seemed very open," directly complimenting her
personality once again and agreeing that he also
had trouble being comfortable with new people.
Driver also jokingly asked Ridley:
"Is there an aspect of working on
Star Wars—it could be anything from
the light saber battles, the travel, the catering,
to getting to see me every day and do
my hair—that was your favorite part?"
To which Ridley replied that, quote, "becoming
besties" with Driver had been the highlight of
the whole thing. It certainly seems like
the two have fun talking to each other,
and it sounds like they had a great time on set.
Finally, at the very end of their conversation,
Driver once again praised Ridley's skill as a
performer, signing off by telling her,
quote, "I think you're brilliant."
Their discussion in V Magazine showcases how
the two performers speak of one another in
glowing terms while keeping the atmosphere
around them lighthearted all the while.
Check out one of our newest
videos right here! Plus,
even more Looper videos about your
favorite stars are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one.